[Musique]
bonsoir bonsoir à toutes et à tous
bienvenue dans ce sens public on est
ensemble pendant 90 minutes de débats
des reportages des chroniques
l'expertise de nos invités avec un
double objectif donné du sens à
l'actualité et vous proposer des clés de
compréhension des crises que nous
traversons voici le sommaire de ce 13
septembre c'est l'une des pires
catastrophes de l'histoire de la
Méditerranée après le passage de la
tempête Daniel la Grèce la Turquie la
Bulgarie et surtout la Libye ravagée par
des pluies dit viennes et des
inondations un épisode météo extrême
appelée à ce multiplier en Libye c'est
la rupture de deux barrages qui
expliquent un bilan effroyable encore
imprécis des milliers de morts au moins
10 000 disparus plus de 30 000 personnes
déplacées nous tenterons de tirer les
leçons de ce drame sur le plan
climatique et géopolitique juste après
les titres dans une minute et puis dans
trois quarts d'heure zoom sur les
élections sénatoriales qui se tiennent
le 24 septembre prochain le portrait
robot des candidats les nouvelles
personnalités attendues et puis le rôle
de contre-pouvoir de la chambre haute
symbolisée par les commissions
d'enquêtes certaines ont passionné les
Français comme celles sur les cabinets
de conseil
j'ai été scotché quand même du 8,6
millions de vues des centaines de
milliers de d'impact je sais pas comment
on appelle ça précisément c'était
effectivement assez
quelque part un peu vertigineux mais
vraiment vertigine c'était donc ça c'est
un sujet qui a intéressé le citoyen on
décortique les enjeux de ces élections
sénatoriales dans notre débat politique
du jour mais d'abord donc les dernières
images les dernières informations en
provenance de la Libye résumée par
Cécile Sixou
imaginez même la couleur de la mer a
changé en ce troisième jour de trajet le
journaliste qui filme ces images non
revient toujours pas dans la ville de
Derna à l'est de la Libye le passage de
la tempête Daniel et ses violons
inondations ont laissé place à un
paysage de désolation
les immeubles et les ponts ont été
emportés par des coulées debout les
routes détruites et des milliers
d'habitants en péril de 1300 selon un
premier bilan
la situation dans la ville de dera est
très difficile nous avons mis en place
un hôpital de campagne à la Faculté de
droit et l'hôpital est actuellement
opérationnel et son personnel coordonne
avec les équipes spécialisées la
récupération des corps et les premiers
soins aux blessés plus de 5000 personnes
sont encore portées disparus et plus de
30 000 habitants ont été déplacés dans
ce pays qui n'était pas préparé à un tel
phénomène climatique selon ce
climatologue spécialiste des événements
extrêmes la tempête Daniel qui a
commencé sa route en Turquie en Grèce et
en Bulgarie a été attiré sur les côtes
libyennes par les températures très
élevées de la mer réchauffement
climatique les émissions des gaz et
desserts qui augmentent la température
de la méditerranéenne bien au-delà des
saisons ces chaleurs et cette humidité
et à disposition pour transformer
cette énergie en orage et donc l'orage
les orages s'organisent autour d'un
centre de basse pression et crée en
conditions cycloniques une circulation
cyclonique qui insiste sur les mêmes
zones pendant plusieurs heures
on se dirige actuellement vers l’égypte
et Israël mais il se dissipe il ne
devrait donc pas faire de nouveau dégâts
on tire les premières leçons de ces
inondations sur le plan climatique sur
le plan géopolitique avec Françoise
Vimeu bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes
climatologue directrice de recherche
institut de recherche pour le
développement David rigouler rose
bonsoir et bienvenue vous êtes
chercheurs à l'Institut français
d'analyse stratégique chercheur associé
à l'IRIS et rédacteurs en chef de la
revue oriente stratégique batterie
bonsoir bienvenue à vous aussi géographe
directrice de la revue Hérodote qui a
consacré l'un de ses numéros à la
libellibie géopolitique du chaos
j'accue également Mathieu croissanto
éditorialise politique François Mathieu
bienvenue à vous Françoise vimaux on va
commencer avec vous pour caractériser
cette cette tempête Daniel donc qui a
frappé la Libye aussi plusieurs pays
méditerranéen qu'est-ce qu'on peut en
dire qu'est-ce qu'elle a de particulier
cette tempête alors d'abord c'est une
tempête que qu'on appelle le médicament
c'est la contraction de Méditerranée et
puis de Hurricane pour la traduction en
anglais de ouragan et en fait c'est
c'est une tempête spécifique qui a la
forme et des caractéristiques d'un
cyclone tropical on le voit très bien
d'ailleurs quand on regarde les images
satellites et parmi ces caractéristiques
malheureusement de manière dramatique il
y a ces quantités de pluie énorme et
comme le disait mon collègue David et
faranda et les cyclones ce genre de
tempête se nourrissent en fait de la
l'énergie de la température de la mer la
mer Méditerranée particulièrement chaude
en surface et sur en fait le les
premiers mètres 50 60 mètres et donc ça
ça vient nourrir cette tempête qui a
d'abord touché la graisse et aussi la
Turquie après elle est revenue en
Méditerranée c'est rechargé en humidité
en énergie et puis la circulation
atmosphérique finalement là entraînait
vers la Libye méditer donc ouragan
Méditerrané est-ce que c'est un nouveau
mot qui a été créé du fait justement du
réchauffement climatique et de ces
épisodes extrêmes à répétition alors en
fait c'est des situations
météorologiques que l'on connaît
plusieurs années il va falloir attendre
l'étude d'attribution à qui va nous dire
si vraiment cet événement enfin a priori
oui cet événement il est dopé par le
changement climatique mais à quel point
il est dopé et ce qui est absolument
exceptionnel ici c'est les quantités de
pluie qui ont été déversés par ce
système
je me tourne vers vous David rigolo
peut-être on va on va comme ça alterner
dans ce débat en permanence entre
l'analyse climatologique face et
l'analyse politique géopolitique parce
qu'elles sont liées pour expliquer le
bilan effroyable est-ce que à quel point
la Libye était en mesure de faire face
ou pas d'ailleurs à un tel épisode à une
telle tempête ce qu'il faut rappeler
c'est qu'effectivement c'est quand même
à quelque chose qui était qui était
attendu parce que c'est lié à des
changements qui sont relativement
récents dans leur manifestations même si
la population était prévenue par les
autorités notamment par le Centre météo
libyen mais manifestement il y avait il
y avait une sous-estimation
vraisemblablement par la population des
dégâts essentiel par ailleurs ce greffe
à cette sous-estimation les séquelles de
la guerre de la guerre civile et
notamment du fait que Bernard était une
ville qui était indéfiev de l'État
islamique qu'elle a fait l'objet de
combat très dur elle a été reprise par
le maréchal à la star en 2018 donc les
bâtiments ont été abîmés il y a pas
d'entretien il y a un déficit de
gouvernance concernant les
infrastructures il y a la question du
barrage donc tous ces éléments conjugués
évidemment explique le bilan qui est
terrible mais est-ce que j'ai bien elle
ressemble à quoi cette région dont on
parle le j'avoue j'ai je l'ai apprise
j'ai appris ce nom en préparant
l'émission Cyril
en fait il y a deux grandes régions en
Libye une qui se trouve à l'ouest qui
est d'ailleurs en ce moment sous
contrôle d'un gouvernement reconnu au
niveau international qui contrôle pas
d'ailleurs une très très grande portion
de la Libye et puis il y a un autre
ensemble la sirenaïque mais aussi tout
le sud on voit la carte pendant que vous
vous et qui passe aussi au sud de la
zone de Tripoli qui est sous le contrôle
effectivement
du général Lafna qui c'est là qui a du
pétrole c'est dans en siènaïque pardon
qui a du pétrole il y en a pas du côté
de Tripoli qui n'ont pas été touchés les
ports
d'expédition du pétrole on
refonctionnait des hier et peut-être
même dès lundi donc c'est pas là la
catastrophe est sur le plan humain était
froyable mais elle aurait pu être encore
plus effroyable si ça s'était produit
sur la zone pétrolière mais comme elle
est plutôt un peu à l'intérieur des
terres ça ne pouvait pas donner la même
gravité et la sirène naïque c'est une
région c'est-à-dire très ancienne de la
de la Libye le roi de Libye le souverain
de Libye qui s'est réfugié au moment de
la prise de pouvoir
parc d'avis à Londres était une des
grandes on va dire en fait tu es très
grande tribu qui dominer tout cet espace
là mais la Libye c'est quand même un
ensemble de tribus alors pas raisonner
seulement comme de d'État nation comme
nous on a l'habitude de le faire alors
je reste avec vous Béatrice on a vu deux
cartes s'afficher on va voir la seconde
de ces cartes et à propos de la ville de
Bernard on va on va voir surtout une
image vidéo pardon je suis pas assez
précis pour la pour la régie et je m'en
excuse une image vidéo où on voit la
ville avant et après le passage
attendait et surtout après la rupture
des deux barrages c'est impressionnant
on a vraiment je pense qu'on va voir ces
images c'est impressionnant donc voilà
la ville avant
et on la voit ensuite après on a
l'impression qu'elle s'est transformée
en un en un gigantesque debout là aussi
je fais appel à la géographie c'est quoi
cette ce cette région cette région
littorale méditerranéenne on a expliqué
effectivement ce phénomène de cyclone
tropical qui s'est produit mais il y a
juste en arrière-plan une petite chaîne
de montagne elle est pas très très haute
c'est 600 700 700 mètres mais il est
évident que elle joue son rôle aussi
dans la gravation du processus est-ce
que quand vous avez les vents chargés
d'humidité qui rencontre un obstacle de
relief il s'élève phénomène de
convection il pleut déjà or on se trouve
avec une montagne qui est très sèche on
est quand même en fin d'été donc il y a
plus beaucoup de végétations il y en a
jamais énormément parce qu'on est quand
même sur un climat très aride et du coup
vous avez une érosion massive qui parce
qu'on est sur quelque chose on est très
près de la mer donc c'est pas très haut
mais néanmoins ça descend très très vite
donc on va avoir si vous voulez des flux
d'eau boueuses et puis à la fin de l'été
il y a des déchets il y a tout ce qu'on
a acheté dans dans les jouets de voilà
et qui vont aussi
entraîner et aggraver ces flux très très
important puis il est tombé une quantité
d'eau
sans doute David rigolait à raison
l'entretien des infrastructures n'était
pas forcément les mieux qu'on puisse
espérer sans aucun doute mais encore on
sait pas si c'est ça qui peut expliquer
que les barrages et craquer mais c'est
surtout qu'ils ont dû ils pouvaient pas
absorber si vous voulez trois ou quatre
fois leur quantité on va y revenir
là-dessus sur les infrastructures il y
aura l'adaptations Matthieu cette
question vous disiez que c'était un
phénomène connu
identifié est-ce qu'on a des précédents
dans l'histoire alors dans cette région
en fait ce qui est intéressant et je
l'ai appris en préparant l'émission
c'est que cette région a déjà été
soumise à des pluies torrentielles mais
pas à ce point là et il y a eu des
inondations vraiment dramatiques dans
les années 40 50 60 et c'est ça qui a
fait que les deux barrages ont été
construits en amont parce qu'il faut se
compare parce que faut bien comprendre
c'est que cette ville elle est en aval
d'une vallée qui descend des montagnes
que vous décriviez et donc l'utilité de
ces deux barrages était vraiment de
protéger la ville de ces inondations on
en parlera peut-être là on voit vraiment
un exemple de mal adaptation qui pour
moi est terrifiant parce que il y a eu
un sentiment de sécurité pour la ville
derrière qui s'est développée on a
construit des routes des infrastructures
des bâtiments publics et privés et
est-ce que ces barrages étaient bien
dimensionnés on en reparlera et puis
est-ce qu'ils étaient entretenus alors
il y a la question du système d'alerte
jeu j'accueille avec nous alors par
téléphone malheureusement le Duplex ne
fonctionne pas mais c'est pas grave ça
arrive Guy benaroche qui est sénateur
écologiste des Bouches-du-Rhône bonsoir
est-ce que vous m'entendez bien
dimanche soir je vous écoute
attentivement bon on l'a dit en
préambule ce cet épisode cette tempête
Daniel elle a elle a frappé plusieurs
pays méditerranéen est-ce que sur les
systèmes d'alarme les systèmes d'alerte
cyclonique est-ce que pour vous ils sont
adaptés est-ce qu'il faut les renforcer
quelles leçons vous tirer d'une
catastrophe comme celle-là s'il faut en
tirer
des leçons sur le sur les alertes face à
des phénomènes climatiques qui
prennent de plus en plus de d'intensité
et dont on peut même s'ils ont existé
par le passé penser que leur intensité
éventuellement leur récurrence a
tendance à devenir plus importantes
booster qu'il sort par le la hausse des
températures qui est en plus dans le
bassin avait été sur le bassin
méditerranéen supérieur à priori d'après
ce que j'ai lu y compris chez le GIEC ou
même chez les Grecs et le qui est le qui
est de la déclinaisons régionales des
groupes d'expert climatiques donc c'est
ce changement climatique cette hausse
des températures elle était encore plus
importante en Méditerranée que dans
d'autres secteurs du monde et comme cela
a été dit effectivement c'est c'est ça
ça amplifie à certains de phénomènes
dont qui sont liés à tout le cycle de
l'eau d'ailleurs sécheresse inondations
incendie de forêt etc voilà on le voit
là en l'occurrence ça s'est passé en
Grèce en Turquie en Libye avec les
répercussions qu'on connaît au niveau de
la vie de millions de gens est-ce qu'on
en tire aujourd'hui suffisamment les
conséquences
prévisionnelles non mais on n'en tient
pas plus les conséquences on en a pas
tiré assez vite et on a encore tendance
à pas retirer totalement les
conséquences aussi au niveau de à la
fois de la lutte contre la continuation
du de l'augmentation des températures et
la les mesures à prendre pour s'adapter
à un changement de température dont on
sait maintenant une la température dont
on sait maintenant que de toute façon
avec l'inertie nécessaire entre les
mesures que l'on prend et les résultats
de ces mesures on sait que de toute
façon elles vont continuer à augmenter
la question c'est comment on fait pour
limiter ce gros risque pardon de vous
vous interrompre notamment effectivement
sur les les mesures de l'adaptation
peut-être les infrastructures c'est l'un
des thèmes de de ce débat Françoise
Vimeux
il y a effectivement je vous pose un peu
la même question parce que peut-être
qu'elle est que je suis à côté de la
plaque quand je la pose mais les alertes
cycloniques d'abord est-ce que ça
fonctionne est-ce qu'on peut précisément
se dire tiens ce cyclone ou ce
médicament il est beaucoup plus puissant
que les précédents donc attention est-ce
que ça fonctionne oui alors de manière
générale à l'alerte cyclonique elle peut
être donnée 24 à 48 heures à l'avance on
a fait énormément de progrès sur la
prévision de la trajectoire de ces
phénomènes que ce soit un cyclone
tropical ou que ce soit ce médicament on
a progresser sur l'évolution de
l'intensité de ces phénomènes mais on
est très capable et on le voit même dans
nos outre-mer on est très capable de
dire 24-48 heures à l'avance attention
alerte alerte rouge et puis alerte rouge
on sait ce qu'il faut faire les gens
restent chez eux etc là de ce que j'ai
compris il y a eu vous l'avez dit
d'ailleurs une alerte des services
météorologiques en revanche cette alerte
elle a pas été a priori entendu par la
population locale ça veut dire peut-être
que là il y a aussi un problème de
sensibilisation et cette population ne
se rend peut-être pas compte de l'effet
que peut avoir ce genre de système je me
souviens qu'après la catastrophe de
Vaison-la-Romaine en France on s'était
notamment questionné sur le système de
d'alerte de sirènes qui pouvait se
déclencher pour avertir la population et
là aussi il y a une acculturation du
risque
peut-être qu'on a progressé en France et
que dans d'autres pays on a habituel que
sous les tropiques oui peut-être qu'il
faut dire aussi ici c'est que les
inondations elle est elle est
certainement composite c'est-à-dire la
pluie torrentielle pro simplement une
onde de tempête c'est à dire cette
submersion marine qui a dû arriver quand
même sur le littoral le ruissellement de
l'eau qui est tombé sur ces reliefs et
puis bien évidemment c'est ces barrages
qui ont cédé donc là c'est vraiment
dramatique mais est-ce que vous vous
souvenez de ce qui s'était passé à Alger
à Babel Oued souvenez-vous où on avait
eu le loyer de Bab El Oued la porte de
l'oued vous satiété une crue d'une
rapidité phénoménale qui avait détruit
sur son passage grande partie du
quartier de Bab El Oued de part et
d'autre de ce qui est en fait le tracé
de le web avec des dégâts qui avaient
été absolument que le Colosso c'était
pas le même tout à fait même type de
phénomènes météorologiques que vous avez
décrit mais dans les phénomènes
méditerranéens en fin d'été on a des
vraiment des des comment des accidents
météorologiques avec des conséquences
qui sont extrêmement importantes autre
chose auquel j'ai repensé des souvenez
souvenez-vous des grandes inondations je
crois que c'était en 2021 en Allemagne
et en Belgique où on a eu des
inondations qui ont surpris tout le
monde c'était aussi je crois enfin d'été
si je me trompe pas avec vraiment tout
le monde a été surpris par ça donc des
phénomènes de très forte intensité avec
énormément de pluie c'est on pense
toujours le dérèglement climatique en
fonction de la sécheresse plutôt et
jamais en fonction de l'inondation et je
crois qu'on aura bien plus de morts par
inondation qu'on en aura par la suite de
des études d'attribution vous l'avez
évoqué tout à l'heure je trouve que
c'est un point important je reviens sur
le l'aspect on va dire un peu plus
politique géopolitique l'un des effets
aggravant de cette catastrophe on en a
dit un mot c'est le chaos qui règne en
Libye je vous propose d'entendre sur ce
thème le général Dominique trinquant il
était sur LCI ce matin
cette catastrophe est une catastrophe
écologique mais aussi due à l'absence de
l'État et la situation que vous décrivez
les barrages qui souhaitent qui n'ont
pas probablement pas été entretenues les
maisons qui ont été construites en dépit
du bon sens
c'est aussi une des causes de la
catastrophe David rigoulère rose on se
pose la question du du manque de suivi
peut-être autour de ces infrastructures
là je viens vraiment sur la question des
barrages est-ce que il y a un manque de
moyens ou un manque d'argent est-ce que
la Libye c'est un pays pauvre ah non
c'est pas un pays pauvres c'est un pays
riche il y a beaucoup de pétrole
simplement la situation politique enfin
le chaos Kadhafi évidemment à laminer
d'abord il y avait pas de culture
étatique au sens classique du terme en
libyens avec le système Kadhafi et
ensuite il y avait un système de
prébendes et d'allégeance on retrouve la
variable tribale et donc il y avait il y
avait pas une organisation étatique
comme on voit au Maroc par exemple avec
le drame que vient de connaître le Maroc
c'est un État organisé qui arrive à
prendre en charge effectivement les
conséquences d'une catastrophe comme un
tremblement de terre là non et ils
peuvent d'autre moins le faire que alors
il y a pas de culture effectivement de
prévention du risque mais parce que ça
fait plusieurs années que le pays a
sombré dans le chaos et en l'occurrence
effectivement il y a un déficit de
gouvernance à tous les niveaux qui ne
peut qu'amplifier évidemment les
conséquences d'un phénomène qui à la
décharge de la population et quand même
pas courant enfin c'est lié à des
modifications qui sont relativement
récentes et à laquelle ce type de
population n'est pas encore préparé donc
ça tous ces éléments évidemment
convergent pour donner une dimension
dantesque à ce qui vient se passer
Françoise Vimeu c'est aussi une
conséquence du réchauffement climatique
cette sorte de de je sais pas quel temps
il double peine pour les pays les plus
pauvres ou les moins organisés
c'est-à-dire que quand une catastrophe
les frappe elle a souvent des
conséquences encore plus graves
qu'ailleurs oui en fait on sait que dans
le risque il y a trois composantes vous
avez d'abord l'aléa climatique et donc
là on est tous égaux devant l'aléa
climatique on a aussi des cyclones en
Floride en revanche après il y a
l'exposition donc là cette ville elle
est particulièrement exposée elle est
derrière deux barrages on parlera voilà
qui ont cédé et puis il y a la
vulnérabilité et la vulnérabilité c'est
ça qui met le doigt sur les pays pauvres
c'est la double peine parce qu'en fait
il y a à la fois l'aléa à la fois ils
sont exposés et il y a une très grande
vulnérabilité et la reconstruction je ne
sais pas comment ça peut se passer dans
ce genre de territoire Guy benaroche
revient vers vous je pense que vous êtes
toujours avec nous au téléphone il y a
c'est aussi une question de solidarité
internationale il y a eu des promesses
qui ont été faites par les pays les plus
riches au pays les plus pauvres une
sorte de dette climatique à à payer on
n'a pas tout à fait fini de la payer
est-ce que vous dites ça
on est loin d'avoir fini de la payer en
fait dans la réalité c'est l'objet de
discussion
à chaque Coop vous savez chaque opticien
à cette comparais bien qu'il y a
certains de pays qui ont aujourd'hui en
fait subissent
réchauffement climatique qui on le sait
aussi est dû essentiellement au pays les
plus riches au pays de la paix quand je
parle depuis les plus riches je vais
dire au pays les plus développés
industriellement et économiquement parce
que la Libye est bien plus riche mais
pour autant les Libyens globalement sont
pas des paris voilà il y a pas une
activité non plus économique ou autre
qui justifierait la richesse vient du
pétrole donc c'est une richesse
aléatoire et éphémère on va dire ça quoi
de cette façon là oui oui il y a une
dette qui est pas payée du coup vous ne
savez très bien il y a un certain nombre
de paysans on y est on y est arrivé on y
est pas encore non on n'est pas encore
on n'est pas encore et puis il y a
certains groupes de de pays qui ne
souhaitent pas aller de l'avant parce
qu'il considère que la part prise dans
le dans le dans le paiement dans la
dette climatique par les pays développés
qui ont contribué plus que les autres à
cette dette climatique n'est pas
suffisante c'est un sujet costaud de
discussion et puis pour parler de la
Libye je rajouterais en plus que ces
dernières la Libye en dehors du pétrole
et des incidences politiques étaient
essentiellement connus aussi faut pas
l'oublier par le fait qu'il y a des
milliers de de migrants qui arrivent de
tout un tas de pays africains pour des
raisons à la fois climatiques et
économique et qui se retrouvèrent Libye
donc c'est un sujet aussi important qui
explique aussi d'ailleurs
la difficulté à l'état liée à
s'organiser et l'existence toujours d'un
certain nombre de modes qui qui vivent
de de de trafic économique ou de trafic
sur le bilan ou autre un pantalon merci
je restais avec nous j'aurais dû une ou
deux autres questions à vous poser sur
ce point béatrisible votre avis là
j'essaye de voilà de temps en temps on
zoom sur la Libye là je dézoome sur la
situation des pays les plus pauvres face
aux face au réchauffement climatique
quand on dit les pays les plus pauvres
une grande partie de la population est
pauvre ça veut pas dire que l'ensemble
du pays les richesses du pays ne soient
pas importantes
la rappeler la Libye n'est pas un pays
pauvre mais il y a des pauvres en Libye
et sans même nombreux mais c'est
important de le préciser
mais à quel point les pays les plus
riches doivent accompagner la
transformation environnementale on va
dire ça comme ça des pays les plus
pauvres
celles qui doivent faire eux ça serait
déjà pas si mal avant d'aller s'occuper
des autres on pourrait déjà voir ce
qu'on a à faire à faire chez nous ce
qu'on a à faire au niveau européen quand
on voit que le pacte vert sera sans
doute remis en cause peut-être bon donc
c'est déjà balayant devant notre propre
porte avant d'aller expliquer ce qu'on
doit faire ce qu'on doit faire aux
autres dans la mesure où ils sont loin
d'être ceux qui participent le plus
effectivement au dérèglement climatique
donc ça ne veut pas dire qu'il faille
pas donner d'argent ça veut pas dire
qu'il ne faut pas aider à passer mais il
faut assurément le faire et c'est utile
mais comment voulez-vous être crédible
quand soi-même prenez l'exemple des
États-Unis par exemple ou même un
certain nombre de forces politiques
européennes n'acceptent pas des
changements qui sont absolument
nécessaires alors il y a la dette donc
c'est la mauvaise conscience voilà donc
on doit
mais je pense que c'est pas vraiment
bien comme ça qu'il faut poser de mon
point de vue des problèmes et là encore
je sors du calibien David rigolérose
c'est quand même une réponse qui est
souvent faite par les pays les plus
pauvres en développement de la planète
quand on leur dit
avancer en matière de lutte contre le
réchauffement ah oui ça a compté ça on
le voit bien d'ailleurs avec les pays du
ce qu'on appelle un peu aujourd'hui le
sud global c'est à dire qu'il y a une
appellation un peu bon pour tout un peu
fournée en revanche il y a effectivement
des pays qui ceux qui ont des des
exigences économiques de développement
et qui sont et qui reprochent aux
Occidentaux effectivement
de pas assumer des responsabilités par
rapport c'est-à-dire dans différents
ciel des efforts qui doivent être
fournis par les uns et par les autres
donc c'est un débat récurrent qui avec
l'Inde avec avec le Brésil et d'autres
et d'autres pays effectivement et
notamment l'Afrique donc c'est très
compliqué à gérer parce que ça
supposerait une gouvernance globale qui
est parasitée de toute façon toujours
géopolitiquement par des intérêts
contradictoires et c'est ça qui obéir
évidemment le la réussite
du de ce qui est aujourd'hui nécessité
absolue quand on voit ce qui se passe à
l'échelle de la planète Mathieu mais ça
veut dire qu'au fond il va y avoir une
forme de double investissement à la fois
un investissement dans cette transition
écologique est nécessaire pour essayer
de lutter contre le réchauffement
climatique et un investissement dans la
prévention de nouveaux risques aussi et
tous les pays vont devoir voir sur leurs
infrastructures tiennent la route pour
pour obtenir des chocs climatiques oui
oui c'est ce que vous dites et pour les
pays du Sud il faut bien différencier
deux choses il y a d'abord ce qu'on
appelle les pertes des dommages c'est à
dire comment en fait on va aider la
reconstruction suite en fait à une
catastrophe climatique et là on est
entièrement responsable en tant que pays
du Nord si je fais quelque chose de très
binaire et ça c'est discuté pendant les
cops les Conférences des Parties qu'on a
tous les ans et puis l'autre aspect
c'est comme on accompagne le
développement de ces pays mais un
développement décarboné alors vous
l'avez dit on n'est pas le meilleur
exemple mais on a quand même des
techniques on a quand même un
savoir-faire et donc la transition
le la transmission de ce savoir-faire
elle est absolument indispensable et
bien sûr derrière il y a des
financements et qui sont pas à la
hauteur vous avez parlé des 100
milliards mais la question elle va se
poser là en Libye comment aider un pays
on a décrit comme totalement chaotique
avec un état fracturé où va aller
l'argent quelle garantie on va voir que
cet argent soit utilisé à bon escient
enfin ce sont des vraies questions le
problème de la redistribution notamment
de l'argent par la rampe pétrolière est
vous proposer puisque c'est un sujet
quand même très sensible puisque le pays
produit un million deux de barils par
jour il a réussi à réhausser mais comme
les institutions sont dysfonctionnelles
il y avait deux branches de la Banque
centrale il y a le problème du
gouvernement reconnu à Tripoli mais en
réalité quand on regarde la carte que
vous avez montré d'ailleurs tout à
l'heure n'est pas le reflet d'arrêter
sur le terrain parce que les deux tiers
du pays en fait sont sous le joues de
appStar donc plutôt de la sirenaïque
donc et en même temps une empreinte
turque très importante à Tripoli donc
évidemment une logique de reconstruction
dans un environnement aussi
dysfonctionnel c'est c'est très très
compliqué alors Mathieu vous avez posé
la question et de corruption employons
le mot Matthieu vous avez posé la
question des infrastructures ça tombe
bien c'est le dernier thème de de ce
débat mais d'abord on va appeler
mathiasarayza à me rejoindre pour faire
une sorte de bilan de cette été
méditerranéen Mathias vous pouvez
rentrer sur ce plateau
est-ce qu'il est là oui bonsoir Mathias
bienvenue on va on va rappeler donc là
on focus sur la Libye mais ça a été un
été particulièrement frappant compliqué
en Méditerranée absolument les images
qui nous arrivent de Libye ne sont
malheureusement pas les seules images
dramatiques que l'on a pu voir pendant
l'été sur tout le pourtour méditerranéen
dans ce cas on parle de la tempête
Daniel cette même tempête qui frappait
au début du mois de septembre là Turquie
la Grèce ou même la Bulgarie faisant
plusieurs dizaines de victimes mortelles
et des milliers de déplacés on parle là
de pluie diluvienne dans des niveaux
historiques le 4 septembre dernier dans
l'est de la Grèce en 24 heures ce sont
entre 600 et 800 mm de précipitation qui
sont tombées en un peu plus de 24 heures
alors à titre de comparaison en moyenne
par an il tombe en Grèce 650 mm de pluie
alors c'est un épisode très violent
intervenu seulement quelques jours après
une énième vague de chaleur dans la
région alors justement on va faire être
un peu précis sur cette vague de chaleur
avec des
des températures records quelle chaleur
hein c'est dite vague de chaleur se sont
enchaînés à un tel rythme qu'il était
même difficile de préciser leur début et
leur fin alors en juillet d'abord et
bien l'Italie la Grèce mais aussi les
pays du Maghreb et le sud de l'Espagne
entre autres ont suffoqué on parle de
plus de 42 degrés des jours durant il y
a eu 42 degrés enregistrés encore ce 44
à Athènes 45 en Catalogne ou même 46 en
Sicile des températures qui répétaient
dans la longueur intensifie et agrave
des phénomènes de sécheresse et donc en
conséquence et bien des incendies Thomas
comme celui qui a connu la Grèce
mi-juillet avec plus de 150 000 hectares
ravagés par les flammes il s'agit à date
du plus grand incendie enregistré dans
l'Union européenne alors Mathias c'est
phénomène on a commencé à l'évoquer
pourraient se multiplier également en
France oui on a tous forcément en
mémoire les ravages de la tempête Alex
dans la vallée de la Roya dans les
Alpes-Maritimes il y a bientôt trois ans
là aussi et bien quantité d'eau tombée
sur le département atteignent des
niveaux sans pareil jusqu'à 500 mm
localement en quelques heures seulement
il y avait alors été question d'une d'un
épisode méditerranéen fréquent en France
en enregistre entre 1 et 8 par an en
moyenne mais c'est un épisode qui
pourrait à terme s'intensifier et donc
avec cet épisode c'est dégâts car selon
Météo France sur les 50 dernières années
l'intensité des épisodes méditerranéens
a augmenté on le voit de plus de 22%.
merci beaucoup Mathias pour toutes ces
informations Françoise Vimeu je reviens
à cette question la d'étude
d'attribution comment on va rentrer un
peu dans le détail faire un peu de
pédagogie comment après un épisode comme
celui de la Roya ou là celui qu'on vient
de vivre en Méditerranée comment vous
pouvez nous dire oui ou non c'est lié au
réchauffement climatique alors en fait
déjà la question qu'on se pose c'est que
est-ce que cet événement aurait pu
arriver dans un climat non modifié par
l'homme et là donc on fait des des
simulations climatiques un grand nombre
de simulations climatiques pour avoir
une bonne statistique et puis on regarde
si dans un climat le non modifié avec
quand même une situation météorologique
par ailleurs qui ressemble à ce qu'on a
là cet événement se produit et si cet
événement se produit est-ce que son
intensité est la même et c'est ça
l'étude d'attribution qui va nous faire
dire ben cet événement aurait été
impossible dans un climat non modifiez
pas l'homme ou il aurait été possible
mais il aurait été très rare ou alors il
aurait été possible mais l'intensité
aurait été beaucoup plus faible et c'est
ça les études d'attribution c'est dire à
quel point ce phénomène est amplifié
dopé par le changement climatique et
donc ce que l'on voit quand même
aujourd'hui en tout cas pour les vagues
de chaleur c'est que la plupart des
vagues de chaleur on arrive à les
attribuer au changement climatique pour
les pluies torrentielles
c'est la même chose mais il faut il faut
quand même attendre l'étude pour le dire
et intuitivement on comprend pourquoi
c'est lié au changement climatique c'est
parce que simplement quand vous avez une
atmosphère plus chaude elle peut
contenir beaucoup plus de vapeur d'eau
la mer s'évapore beaucoup plus
l'atmosphère est très contente elle
garde cette vapeur d'eau et puis quand
vous avez une situation météorologique
qui vient refroidir cette atmosphère et
bien toute l'eau qui est contenue elle
retombe et l'augmentation des pluies
c'est entre 10 et 20% par degré de
réchauffement ça dépend du système
météorologique que l'on observe alors je
repose la question de Mathieu sur les
infrastructures vous avez pas eu le
temps d'y répondre tout à l'heure je
sais pas je vais dire les les
canalisations les barrages m'ont mais
même les canalisations le diamètre de
nos est-ce que tout ça est adapté à la
nouvelle situation qui qui qui est déjà
là et évidemment non en fait nos villes
ne sont pas adaptées à réceptionner
autant d'eau en si peu de temps on peut
peut-être rappeler quand on parle de une
hauteur depuis de 1 mm 1 mm c'est un
litre par mètre carré quand on parle de
600 mm c'est 600 litres d'eau par mètre
carré en moins de 24 heures donc non
bien sûr nos infrastructures elles ne
sont pas dimensionnées pour ça et on a
même des infrastructures dans les pour
lesquelles on pense que ça va nous
protéger c'est le cas des digues par
exemple qui ne sont pas dimensionnés et
c'est terrible parce que j'en parlais
tout à l'heure ça peut créer un
sentiment de sécurité se dire mais on a
une digue on peut se mettre derrière
mais si elle a pas été dimensionnée pour
des événements extrêmes que l'on va
connaître dans quelques années quelques
décennies c'est encore plus dramatique
ça pose la question de des est-ce qu'on
est prêt à investir suffisamment pour
s'adapter parce que c'est ces deux ça
dont on est en train de parler si
comment s'il faut commencer à changer
toutes les canalisations de nos villes
pour évacuer les eaux alors
plus ils viennent ça sera pas dans
toutes les villes parce que toutes les
villes seront pas le risque sera pas le
même partout mais il est évident que sur
les grandes villes méditerranéennes du
sud de la France oui la question pour
pourra se poser alors bien sûr on va
dire il faudrait le faire mais il y a eu
à la suite mais je pense de l'épisode de
la flotte qui avait eu lieu sur la côte
atlantique et qui avait fait des ravages
extrêmement importants a permis de
j'allais dire de booster tout le travail
sur les risque qu'on doit faire dans
toutes les villes on devait déjà le
faire mais bon ça prenait beaucoup de
temps on est alors tout d'un coup ah il
se passe quelque chose donc on accélère
mais comme c'est la construction
anti-sismique parce que effectivement on
est sur la Méditerranée la plaque
africaine et la plaque hors asiatique
effectivement il peut y avoir un jour un
tremblement de terre à Nice et faire des
des dégâts alors on va nous assurer que
tout est très très bien construit avec
le respect total évidemment de normes
antisismiques mais
on sait qu'il faut le faire mais c'est
beaucoup beaucoup d'argent et beaucoup
de temps commencer qu'il faut supprimer
les passoires thermiques commencez on
sait beaucoup de choses mais à ce
moment-là c'est des changements d'abord
soit il faudra augmenter les impôts pour
ceux qui peuvent en payer soit il faudra
avoir une attitude coercitive on pourra
pas faire ce qu'on veut comme on veut
c'est pas évident moi je pense que l'une
des questions ma c'est aller jusqu'à
l'acceptation sociale véritablement par
une très large partie d'opinion publique
pour qu'on puisse le faire tant qu'on ne
l'a pas et je pense aujourd'hui en
France on ne l'a pas encore et que ceci
va demander beaucoup de temps dernière
chose je pense qu'un Chine on n'a pas
besoin de savoir si les gens sont
d'accord ou pas et que d'une certaine
façon on aura le moyen de dire par la
coercition
d'imposer à la population un certain
nombre de respect de comportements on va
dire et écologique à un prix qui sera
celui de la liberté de la démocratie
mais c'est peut-être la grande puissance
qui ira le plus vite ça c'est un une
partie du débat mais ça mériterait
presque un autre débat je me retourne
vers vous gui benaroche parce que là on
est au cœur de d'une responsabilité
d'élus
de sénateurs des lut territoriales c'est
cette question des infrastructures de
l'investissement que les collectivités
locales mais à effectivement les
citoyens les électeurs sont prêts à
faire pour se préparer à des épisodes
climatiques de plus en plus nombreux et
de plus en plus violents c'est une
réflexion je le sais qui est en cours
oui oui tout à fait alors d'abord il y a
pas très très longtemps le Sénat voté
noir climat entre guillemets loi climat
dans un des volets totalement absent ou
en tout cas presque totalement absent
était justement toutes les mesures qui
consistaient à être résilient au
changement climatique à prendre les
dispositions nécessaires pour en
fonction du changement dont on sait déjà
qu'il va arriver et que même si on
change de trajectoire aujourd'hui on
arrive on n'arrêtera pas c'est à dire
c'est très bien que
certains nombre de degrés etc auxquels
même si demain on arrêtait tout
on va arriver inéluctablement d'ici 2030
2050 et ces mesures là déjà on ne les a
pas prises au mois du projet de loi
climat ça c'est la responsabilité des
politiques alors bien entendu qu'il faut
qu'il y ait une acceptation sociale
derrière puisque les politiques ont
bougé de dire oui mais la coercition
l'écologie punitive etc tout ça ça peut
pas fonctionner etc bon certes il y a
quand même une vraie responsabilité
politique qui est celle quand même que
malgré que nous ayons été alerté par des
scientifiques depuis très longtemps sur
le changement climatique il y en a deux
sur le plateau qui qui nous explique ce
qu'il se passe là encore aujourd'hui
pour autant à votre d'arriver à faire
accepter qu'il y avait vraiment
des problèmes de riches en France
climatique lié à l'activité humaine
rappelez-vous le top d’année que ça
habille aujourd'hui est-ce qu'on va
mettre autant de temps à faire accepter
les conséquences de ce changement
climatique par exemple Méditerranée avec
les épisodes qui sont de plus en plus
intenses et récurrents et qu'il
deviendront les les attributions de ces
phénomènes au changement climatique nous
le montrerons au fur et à mesure est-ce
qu'on arrivera à aller suffisamment vite
dans la prise de décision politique
derrière et la prise de position la
prise de position politique elle c'est
important puisque pour l'instant elle
n'est pas prise et on a du mal à être
crédible vis-à-vis des pays moins riches
que nous et qui sont plus souvent soumis
ou en tout cas qui par leur
vulnérabilité subissent de plein fouet
plus directement que nous les aléas
climatiques ont des difficultés
au niveau de la dette et la deuxième
c'est que nous-même nous ne nous mettons
pas sur des trajectoires
vis-à-vis du du changement climatique et
de sa et de la résilience climatique qui
nous permet d'être crédible pour les
autres c'est-à-dire qu'en fait c'est
bien de dire ce qu'il faut pas faire
mais c'est pas mal si on le fait
nous-mêmes aussi alors qu'on est
aujourd'hui dans les deux le fait pas
suffisamment on a entendu aux avions
merci beaucoup Guy ben Laroche sur
sénateur écologiste des bouches-du-runir
ou il nous reste quelques minutes dans
ce débat vous l'avez compris on on
traite à la fois le l'aspect climat
climatique et géopolitique je reviens à
l'aspect politique pour parler de l'aide
internationale parce que c'est
intéressant ça permet de d'essayer de
comprendre ce qui se joue autour de la
Libye les pays qui sont en première
ligne pour pour aider la Libye la
Jordanie par exemple écouter le
secrétaire général de l'organisation
caritative à chimie de jordanienne on
l'écoute
permanent avec les autorités libyennes
pour évaluer leurs besoins et savoir
s'ils ont besoin d'une aide
supplémentaire dans cet envoi nous nous
sommes concentrés sur les produits de
première nécessité telles que la
nourriture et l'aide d'urgence comme les
tentes les couvertures et tous ceux qui
est nécessaire dans de telles conditions
en plus des colis alimentaires adaptés à
de telles situations
David Rigollet rose là on a cette
réaction jordanienne c'est peut-être pas
le pays le plus influent non plus c'est
la Turquie c'est ça il y en a plusieurs
il y a la Turquie qui est qui est très
très implanté dans la Tripolitaine bon
depuis plusieurs années et donc il y a
offert son aide logiquement et fait écho
à l'aide turc qui soutient le
gouvernement de Tripoli l'aide à porter
par les Émirats de l'autre côté qui
était un qui sont des soutiens du
maréchal after et on retrouve le Qatar
aussi du côté de la Turquie et l'Algérie
du côté des émirats au profit donc voilà
on retrouve en fait les acteurs
géopolitiques préexistants qui offre de
manière consensuelle leur
aide et puis il y a le cas français qui
a qui a aussi offert son aide après
avoir pas reçu de réponse favorable de
la part du Maroc et donc là en tout cas
la France veut manifester sa
disponibilité plus que jamais donc
vous nous parlez on va voir le et de
tweets celui par nos interrompre celui
de du président de la République
Emmanuel Macron solidarité avec le
peuple libyen mobilisation des moyens
pour apporter une aide d'urgence je
pense que voilà le tweeter d'Emmanuel
Macron
et le ministre de l'Intérieur a détaillé
cette aide nous engageons à demande du
président l'hôpital de campagne de la
sécurité civile premier personnel qui
partiront dès ce soir tout pour que tout
soit opérationnel sous 48 heures donc
c'était de là elle est elle est partie
et puis c'est vrai que vu le passif qui
a par rapport à l'intervention
occidentale en 2011 notamment
franco-britannique c'est vrai que il y a
une responsabilité sans doute
particulière
de notre part pour pour aider
effectivement mais est-ce que la libio
parce que vous avez fait la comparaison
avec le Maroc qui a donc on l'a fait une
émission là-dessus cette semaine qui a
privilégié on va dire ça comme ça quatre
pays en tout cas dans un premier temps
est-ce que la Libye est en mesure de
diffuser une partie de l'international
ou est-ce que le pays est tellement
chaotique que c'est pas possible non la
situation du Maroc et la limite n'est
absolument bien sûr c'est absolument pas
comparable parce qu'il y a un état ce
que je disais tout à l'heure au Maroc
alors qu'il y a pas il y a pas de d'État
constitué il y a pas de structure tout
est dysfonctionnel en Libye et donc
c'est vrai que pour ne serait-ce que
pour l'organisation de la c'est très
compliqué parce que alors là c'est
localisé mais il n'en reste pas moins
que c'est très compliqué parce qu'il
faut des relais sur place il faut il y a
des un déficit de légitimité aussi des
interlocuteurs éventuellement et tout ça
c'est très compliqué pour évidemment que
ça soit que laisse soit efficace auprès
des populations avec Béatrice Gibelin
aussi ce qui complique les secours c'est
qu'il y a une seule route c'est ça
évidemment extrêmement Combrée et qui
devrait absolument beaucoup de temps
mais on le voit déjà aussi avec le Maroc
c'est pas facile d'y aller et ça demande
énormément de temps donc dans ces
situations qui sont de toute façon
absolument catastrophique chaotique je
veux dire là on peut pas faire
intervenir directement l'armée puisque
il n'y a pas une armée qu'est-ce que
fait l'état du Maroc il dit à l'armée
allez-y bon voilà et nous on ferait la
même chose si on était dans une
situation difficile on aurait l'armée
qui interviendrait alors là il y a une
armée à l'armée nationale libyenne
d'instar et dans lequel il y a aussi il
y avait les la Russie et il y avait
aussi les troupes de Wagner qui étaient
présentes dans ce coin-là c'est très
faut pas faut pas l'oublier alors il y a
eu un appel de la part de Tripoli du
gouvernement reconnu Anders
internationalement qui a eu une réaction
on va dire unitaire en disant on doit
intervenir on y va ce qui n'est pas rien
non plus hein
si vous voulez que les réseaux sociaux
et les images que le Tripoli il ne peut
pas se taire face à cela il peut pas se
permettre de délaisser la Syrie parce
que ce serait
ce serait un désaveu de sa propre
légitimité merci beaucoup merci à tous
c'était passionnant de de voilà de tirer
des leçons assez rapidement peut-être
trop vite par rapport au temps de la
catastrophe mais en tout cas voilà c'est
ce qu'on a essayé de faire ce soir je
vais rappeler Béatrice Gibelin le je
vais montrer la une de ce numéro de la
revue Hérodote consacrée à la Libye
géopolitique du chaos qui était paru en
2021 je vous dis encore une fois merci
et à bientôt sur public c'est